[Music]
so let's talk about the resurrection
then for any of us here who've
experienced death the death of someone
who is close to us we know how how much
we longed for for the resurrection and
if we were to remove the resurrection
story from which has many manifestations
and all kinds of cultures as a you so my
argument really is is that it's useful
not that it's true or false just that
it's useful so you know so when my
mother was dying the sort of resident
the story would be it hasn't rained for
forty nights the crops are dying
[Music]
everyone's starved and then they died
that's that would be the story there's
no harvest first of all it's a very
difficult story to live with and we have
to live with it
but we will put something between
accepting that we have to live with it
and and and and all the rest of it well
this is this is excellent
this is absolutely good an example of
why I don't think we should divide the
rational and the supernatural quite so
so harshly is a few days after my mother
died I went into a store a shop in
Oxford Circus I wrote about this in in
the cost of living and I saw a pair of
owl earrings and she collected owls and
I thought oh I'll buy those for my
mother and I took them down and I took
them to the cashier and as I handed them
to her I realized my mother was dead and
I sounded like Hamlet said oh no no no
no no I couldn't get out of that shop
fast enough so that's not rational
behavior but it's
but in a way it's it's it's appropriate
behavior it's an appropriate response to
something that the mind can't accept
something signs being taken for miracles
and I think lots of us have that
experience and the grief-stricken I
think it's very tempting to build a
narrative and yeah when my mother died
her name was Stella and my siblings and
I found stars on the ground
sort of in seem to be in droves in
uncommon numbers and it became a sort of
consolation and very true and I think
when the supernatural really becomes of
interest in the course of a human life
is when you think exactly as Deborah's
saying there were these real people
around and now they're not here in an
empirical sense and yet they feel
entirely real I mean I sort of advice
what something your Netflix I sort of
have a sense of what my mum would think
of it or whether she'd be into it or not
and she has sort of a an opinion about
it running in parallel long after her
material life so I think this is just
part of this way of coping with the with
again a sublime thing I think that's
what you're saying that this sort of
idea of the sublime it sometimes death
just cannot be rendered in language and
so it is sort of shattered into glimpses
and signs and charms well the risk a
risk of reverting to the rigid casting
of me there's a sense I understand what
both of you're saying but I think we
want to be a little bit careful about
this I think that when someone's trying
to be too kind of literal minded and
confining what one says beauty's what
scientific there's a tendency to dismiss
the kind of experience you've had is
just complete nonsense and forget about
the me said you said the other hand if
we've become sort of too indulgent of
these things I think it's quite
important important personally to accept
and recognize there the real finality of
death in a sense right now there's an
in-between space and I think perhaps
people find it useful to talk in ways
which have a supernatural feel to them
if you like but it's quite important to
me that we don't fall each other
thinking these things are literally true
I think it is there's a perfectly
reasonable sense in which people who
have died continue to have a presence in
our
world and in our life and you could give
a kind of a boring sort of account of
the ways that is because in a sense we
we live with others you know you we are
in other people's minds almost quite
literally and when we physically
disappear things hang around so you know
we can talk about these things but I
suppose when people if people are gonna
start to sort of say well yes and so
therefore death is the I'm gonna carry
on living in a literal sense that's
where my rationalist humanist I go no
let's not do that let's let's be let's
be a bit more realistic about about what
happens for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you